un flop avant de voir tout ça en avant
flop sequans portes gris fougue et à
coude qui arrive sur un artiste que
j'aime énormément
j'adore j'ai adoré son premier album son
nouvel album sort à peine a franchi
sefiane sauf moi j'adore on adore la
paix tout cas tout ça on adore on n'aime
pas forcément tout ce qui fait mais mais
mais en tout cas musicalement j'aime
beaucoup et là il a donné une cartouche
à quelqu'un qu'on aime encore plus que
lui c'est la petite kelly qui avait rien
demandé la même cartouche
il ya mille cartes way back il a autant
pour moi non mais le gars m'a taclé il a
mis un taquet d'argent de ces de ces
derniers sont donc ils s'appellent
hashtag c'est pas de ma faute d'accord
on écoute ou pas quand acheter
acceptable afin d'analyser ça nous non
non c'est yann jean baptiste say
parcours qu'il retrouve son jus cela-dit
connoté c'est la mort continue pendant
un set pour remonter au café la ramènent
leurs dettes en paix là où le coup de
sonde est ce qu'il a vraiment tort
comment parce que ça m'a choqué kelly je
m'emballe etc total d'accord sinon à
l'écouté des gens week-end vous l'a dit
on se calme quand même nom mais c'est
non mais c'était c'était un mois de
recul c'est pour la rime qui tue avec
toi tu quand on a tu sais en alexandrins
sais si tu avais que qu en fait oui mais
avec mes lames n'y a pas de rythme si
avec ben alaya roc a fella comment vous
êtes au niveau de l'annexé c'est pas
respectueux c'est pas drôle c'est pas
pousser pas classé pg-13 habitué à bien
mieux que ça vraiment j'aime beaucoup ce
n'est pas l'ami jean mais là ça fait
vraiment passé calais pour un objet
enfin c'est vraiment pas content je
reste des non valable et des yeux parce
que là elle n'a pas eu vraiment beaucoup
de fois vous êtes vraiment non je suis
ce n'est pas que je suis vexé mais salah
à la base moi j'aimais bien et là du
coup je trouve ça hyper nas c'est tout
mergen besoin de georges d'ailleurs est
ce qu'il sait que c'est toi ô mon nom
mais pour de vrai ce qu'il appellera
quatre ans même pas est ce qu'il sait
que oui j'essaie qui a way comment je
vous savez qui c'est je sais que je vais
vous dire la vérité il ya deux mois il a
demandé mon numéro
je ne sais pas pourquoi quelqu'un qu'on
a en commun ouais j'ai pas une belle de
lui et là je vois un truc comme ça donc
avec c
prévenir qu'elle assume cette daube
bah voilà peut-être qu'ils voulaient
vous pouvez venir pas illégaux aller et
chérie il va se rattraper je suis sûr
qu'on va faire une prochaine chanson il
va dire kelly vient lire des livres à la
maison
iseli renée délire comme avait pas de
faille du temps mais c'est vrai la peau
va était pas bien toute la journée on
s'était pas les affaires et un petit peu
mais ça va 1 allez c'est pas grave elle
est toujours sur le frère de benjamin
castaldi
maïga en direct bien plus correct
quoique en bas il est bien plus probable
correct quand le frère de benjamin la
bière spécialement à vous aujourd'hui
vous êtes vénérable sur athènes ouvert
ces paquets libé d'obélix arlette
laguiller il va contacter sur wii j'ai
jamais nouvelle s'est passé avec le
phare de castaldi va tout se passe bien
on se voit dimanche
ouais vous avez quelque peu
on va très bien ben voilà vous savez
quoi eh ben c'est vous dire ben vous
serez très salaires femme s'il va faire
comme son frère
vous serez la première du ne regarde
jamais je lui ai dit c'est ton frère
andy rihs qu'est-ce qui cette caisse qui
tu t'étonnes franck est lisible ait à
tout prix
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]